العريقه لم تعد سويسريه بعد اليوم الواح
الشوكولا التي تباع في اكثر من 100 دوله
ستحرم من عباره صنع في سويسرا وتستبدل
بعباره تاسست في سويسرا قانون سويس او
طابع سويسري الذي تم تبنيها عام 2017 لا
يسمح باستخدام رموز الوطنيه السويسريه على
المنتجات التي لا تستوفي معايير الصناعه
السويسريه ومنها انتاج بنسبه 80% من
المواد الخام داخل البلاد ومع انتقال
انتاج بعض خطوط انتاج الالواح الهرميه
الشكل الى سلوفاكيا ستضطر توم للتخلي عن
صوره قمه جبل متر هورن الشهيره والتي تزين
اغلفه منذ اكثر من نصف قرن
علامه صنع او ميد ان ظهرت لاول مره في
انجلترا عام
1887 عندما صدر قانون يجبر الشركات
الاجنبيه التي تصنع منتجات بريطانيه مقلده
ومنخفضه الجوده على توضيح اصل منتجاتها
العلامات التجاريه تدرك التاثير الذي
سيحدثه ملصق صنع فيه على قرار الشراء لذلك
تستخدم بعض الشركات تلك العلامه كاداه
تسويقيه ليس الا هذا يعني انه اذا كانت
الشركه تصنع منتجا في اسيا لقله التكلفه
تكلفه الايادي العامله ثم اضافت التفاصيل
النهائيه في روما فلا يزال بامكانها
استخدام ملصق صنع في ايطاليا لكن في
الولايات المتحده مثلا معاييره وضع علامه
صنع في امريكا صارمه جدا بحسب لجنه
التجاره الفيدراليه يجب ان تكون معظم
الاجزاء التي يصنع منها المنتج مصنوعه
داخل حدود البلاد
استطلاعن اجرته منصه ستاتستا عام 2017 شمل
اكثر من 43 الف مستهلك حول العالم يقيس
درجات الاحترام لملصقات صنع فيه جاءت
المانيا في المركز الاول يليها سويسرا ثم
علامه صنع في الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
على كل ان المزيد انضم لنا الصحفيه
الاقتصاديه سمر يسعد صباحك دائما اهلا بك
المره الجايه نجيب لك طبله خلاص ريهام
زعلت
شكرا سمر طيب كم تكلفه عباره صنع في
السويسرا سمعنا ان هناك شروط جدا صارمه
لوضع هذه العباره ما هي الشروط ايضا صحيح
بدايه لنضع علامه صنع في سويسرا او اف
سويسرا لاند او من السويسرا هي لازم انت
بدايه يعني 20% من سعر لوح شوكولاته التوب
ليرون هو بسبب مكتوب عليها صنع في سويسرا
انت تدفعين 20% من هذا السعر هو بس لانه
مكتوب عليه صناعه في سويسرا اما بالنسبه
للساعات الفاخره اللي لابسينها مثلا رولكس
وغيرها انت دافعه 50% من يعني من السعر بس
لانه عليها صنع في سويسرا حتى مول البراند
بس لانه ممكن ان تصل الى 50% من السعر
بسبب مكتوب عليها صنع في سويسرا ذلك طبعا
بسبب الجوده
عند الناس يعني طول عمرنا شايفينها وعم
ناكل فيها وعارفين انه شايفينها الجبل
السويسريه فجاه بنقول انه هي مش من سويسرا
ومش من بلد المنشا فجاه نقول تصنع بسويسرا
يعني شو بصير
مثل ما قالت سهام هناك قوانين صارمه في
سويسرا وفي اوروبا بصوره عامه مو مثل
امريكا هي من سويسرا ما تغير الموضوع بس
انت ما الك حق تحطين على اي شيء من سويسرا
حسب شروط معينه اول شيء اذا كان لازم يكون
المنتج المواد الغذائيه ثمانين بالمئه
منها مصنعه في سويسرا او من سويسرا اذا
صارت اقل من 80% لنفرض مثلا فتحوا مصنع في
بانسلفينيا او في سلوفاكي هذا مثلا حيقلل
مثلا جوزيه بعدها 70% مصنوع منها من
سويسرا بس لازم 80% بالنسبه لمنتجات
الالبان لازم 100% يكون مثلا الجبن مئه
بالمئه لازم منتج في سويسرا الخدمات مثلا
عندك البنوك يو بي اس لازم المقر والمكتب
الرئيسي والتشغيل يكون في سويسرا يلا
تقدرين تحطين عليه مثلا العلم السويسري
اللي فيه علامه الزائد او تحطين عليه
صناعه او تحطي مصاري بس تستاهل انت
تلقائيا بس تشوفين اي شيء
من المعروف انه بسويسرا هوايه من الاشياء
يتم انتاجها على يد ايدي عاملين مهره جدا
معروفين العاملين في سويسرا بمهارتهم
وسكيلد ومو شي تجاري مو يعني النوعيه
والجميع صحيح مو انه شي تجاري ويتم تصنيعه
بكميات كبيره دائما مثلا الرولكس هسه صار
عليها سرعه طويله تنتظرين يلا تحصلين على
الساعه لانها هاند ميت معروفين بالدقه
معروفين بالابتكار خصوصا مثلا في قطاع
الادويه معروفين ايضا في
حتى بالنسبه للاشياء اللي مصنعه معروفه
الالات تبعتهم تكون اكثر دقه واكثر انه
اكثر ابتكار لانه مثل ما قلنا تصنع بكميات
قليله متصنع بكميات كبيره بس هذا بيعني
انه اجورهم ممكن تكون مرتفعه علشان
نتكلم مثلا موظف البنك وموظف الساعات احنا
نسميه باللغه العامه يعني اللي يفتح كشك
صغير في منطقتنا يصلح ساعات الطيب ممكن 20
درهم طبعا هناك الستيلز مختلفه ويمكن حرام
يكون عنده هذا سكيلز او مهارات جيده مثل
هذا الساعات اللي بسويسرا بس الساعات اللي
بسويسرا يتقاضى بالمتوسط حسب طبعا المهاره
اذا كان جدا ماهر وعنده خبره
6700 دولار بالشهر وهو قريب من راتب
الموظف اللي مثلا في بنك او موظف عادي
عنده 7,000 دولار بالشهر والى بالضبط نفس
القوانين ونفس الحقوق ونفس التامين على
انتقلت الى مصنع فيسوفاكيال هذا يقلل من
سعرها مدى مش مكتوب
والله سؤال جيد هذا حلو ما دورنا عليه راح
ادور عليه والاقيه الاجابه بس ايضا مؤخرا
خسرت في كونسور من شركات فرنسيه وايطاليه
قبل البارحه خسرت دعوه في امريكا رفعتها
على شركه اجبان تستعمل كلمه على الجبن هو
اي نوع من الجمل مصنوع في منطقه جرير بس
هم بامريكا يقولون احنا ما عندنا هاي
القوانين الصارمه وروحوا حطوا اللي تريدوه
على
مثلا بالوقت الحالي اذا الواحد بروح
عالسوبر ماركت يلحق حاله ويجيب اخر اخر
صور حصريه من توب ليرون قبل ما تتغير وهيك
بتكون ارخص
ممكن طبعا ما تعرفين هاي
دائما يسرق عليها اقبال بعدين على السوبر
ماركت شكرا